cinematix samurai are known for their
fierce loyalty deadly precision with the
sword and an unswerving commitment to a
code of honor from Japanese classics to
American takes these are the samurai
movies you absolutely need to watch
before you die the name that rightly
dominates any discussion of great
samurai movies is Akira Kurosawa the
late Japanese director made some of the
best samurai movies ever and he's
generally regarded as one of the most
influential filmmakers of all time I
think he comes from a generation of
filmmakers that were still influenced by
silent films the film most often
associated with Kurosawa is 1954 Seven
Samurai the heroes of this epic film are
Ronin which are samurai without masters
the seven warriors unite to protect a
farming community from merciless bandits
they also train the villagers into a
makeshift militia and the whole thing
culminates in a huge bloody battle if
the plot of Seven Samurai sounds
familiar that's because it's been copied
over and over again a classic Western
the Magnificent Seven is a remake of
Seven Samurai and plenty of other
westerns have found similar inspiration
the story of veteran heroes training
peaceful towns folk into soldiers has
been copied in everything from comedies
like three amigos to episodes of shows
like the Clone Wars and the mandalorian
and the trope of assembling a team has
echoes in heist films like Ocean's
eleven war movies like The Dirty Dozen
and superhero flicks like the Avengers
basically if you love movies then you've
almost definitely seen something
influenced by Kurosawa if you're a fan
of westerns you're likely familiar with
1992's
Unforgiven Clint Eastwood's
oscar-winning film about an aging
gunslinger who sets out on one last job
I'll see you in Hell with money
but what you may not know is that Korean
director Lee Sang el remade Unforgiven
in 2013 with Japanese actor Ken Watanabe
as retired samurai Jubei said in Japan's
Hokkaido frontier the plot of 2013's
unforgiven Hughes pretty closely to the
originals
Jubei and his old friend King go are
lured out of retirement by the promise
of a handsome reward for killing two
brothers who have disfigured a sex
worker they're joined by the younger
Goro who makes bold claims about a
triumphant and violent past
the trio clash with the local lawman
who's determined to stop anyone looking
to make good on the sex workers contract
this is clearly destined to end badly
for everyone involved
Unforgiven is a visually rich morally
challenging epic it's a faithful echo of
its source material with the added
benefit of Watanabe a singular talent
2002's the twilight samurai is a
different kind of samurai movie its hero
say BAE
Iguchi is a low-level poor samurai who
works as a clerk his wife dies early in
the film leaving him to raise his two
daughters alone on a modest stipend when
his old friend Tomo begins to regularly
visit him and help take care of the
girls say BAE falls in love sadly though
he is ashamed of his social status and
initially refuses to marry his old
friend while the Twilight samurai has
its share of swordplay neither action
nor adventures the focus of the film
it's more interested in character than
other typical elements of the genre and
as such say BAE is a lot more relatable
than your average fictional samurai most
samurai movie fans probably don't deal
with a lot of far-reaching adventures
involving assassination and revenge in
their own lives but things like loss
love and the difficult balance between
work and family are much more Universal
concepts the Twilight samurai is a
refreshing and uncharacteristically
upbeat samurai film and that distinction
helped it earn a dozen Japanese Academy
Awards along with an Oscar nomination
for Best Foreign Language Film in the
wake of the Twilight samurai success in
2002 the doors opened for more
filmmakers to dive back into the
long-neglected genre among them was
Shameka who earned praise for his 2010
remake of the 1963 classic 13 assassins
said in 1844 the story follows a group
of samurai determined to take down a
powerful and cruel Lord whose rule could
mean nothing but horror for the future
of Japan despite its direct source
material 13 assassins often feels a lot
like Seven Samurai including its length
at close to two and a half hours 13
assassins begins relatively slowly but
climaxes with a spectacular and
prolonged battle between the heroes and
the villains army it's an epic set piece
that includes an abandoned town
converted into a deadly labyrinth of
booby traps the film is heralded as one
of me Kay's best and it also went a long
way to revitalize the doormat samurai
genre it was nominated for 10 Japanese
Academy Awards and won four of them and
a spectrum culture critic David Harris
wrote me Kay has created a reverential
and vital film in a genre that many may
have thought as moribund and passe as
its subject the plays of William
Shakespeare have remained relevant for
centuries after they were first written
his works have been adapted into
countless movies because they still
speak to audiences today Akira Kurosawa
proved this better than anyone with 1957
s throne of blood his adaptation of
Shakespeare's tragedy Macbeth while
Macbeth is set in Scotland throne of
blood takes place in Japan but besides
the setting change the two stories are
otherwise remarkably similar throne of
bloods protagonist is general washi zu
who at first seems as loyal to his Lord
as any samurai after he's visited by a
strange spirit who tells him that one
day he'll become the lord of spider's
web Castle he tells his wife asaji about
the prophecy just as Lady Macbeth did
with her husband asaji urges her partner
to make the spirits prediction come true
by killing the Lord and taking his place
after that
just like his Shakespearean inspiration
washi zu finds himself well past the
point of no return and on a road that
can only end with a bloodbath
throne of blood is not only essential
for samurai
but for Shakespeare devotees as well as
the Guardian critic Derek Malcolm put it
it remains a landmark of visual strength
and is possibly the finest Shakespearean
adaptation ever committed to the screen
this clever re-imagination of a
Shakespearean classic is always included
among Kurosawa's best one of the most
unique entries on this list is Jim
Jarmusch's 1999 crime drama Ghost Dog
the way of the samurai this one doesn't
take place in Japan and stranger still
we're not sure exactly where in America
it's meant to be set as no city name is
ever provided within the film itself
Forest Whitaker stars as the titular hit
man who binds himself in service to
local mobster Louis after Louis saves
his life but Ghost Dog isn't just any
old hitman when he's not working he
tends to his pigeons meditates and
studies hagakure a collection of
conversations from the early 18th
century about the meaning of the code of
bushido ghost dog sees himself as a
samurai and is a strict follower of
Bushido follow a code I've always given
you I respect the fact that Ghost Dog
continues to work for Louis and
eventually begins taking out his bosses
competition when Louie's life is in
danger has proof enough of his devotion
to the code even after it becomes clear
that Louie isn't returning Ghost Dog
loyalty the hit man refuses to lift a
hand against him ultimately Ghost Dog
the way of the samurai is a uniquely
moving and surprisingly funny film about
a man who refuses to let go of who he is
in the face of a hostile world by the
early 1960s Japanese actor Toshiro
Mifune had already starred in multiple
Akira Kurosawa films in 1961 the two of
them teamed up once again for the first
of a pair of films in which me foon a
played impoverished samurais Sandra Dahl
a name that means 30 years old each
movie would prove to be some of the best
in the entire Canon of the genre when we
first meet Sun Judo in Yojimbo he's
found himself in a town where a feud
between two warring clans is raging
rather than work for one clan or the
other he winds up getting hired by both
sides as part of a secret plan that he
hopes will wipe out both groups
in 1962 Mifune starred in the follow-up
sanju doe in which the title hero teams
up with a group of samurai intent on
fighting a corrupt board some of the
most influential aspects of Yojimbo and
sandra are felt in western cinema
Yojimbo antihero is credited as the
prototype for the similarly immoral man
with no name as played by Clint Eastwood
in Italian director Sergio Leone a
spaghetti-western dollars trilogy the
similarities between these two
characters aren't especially clear in
the more comedic saundra but in a much
darker Yojimbo their shared
characteristics are obvious enough for
anyone to recognize Kill Bill is a
stylistically beautiful revenge epic and
a story too big for a single film it's
also Quentin Tarantino's love letter to
martial arts and samurais cinema in
2003's Kill Bill Vol 1
uma thurman's merciless ex assassin is
known only as the bride when we first
meet her we have no idea why she's
arrived at Vernita green suburban home
in a garish yellow truck or why the two
women perceived to beat the crap out of
each other you can take my word for it
your mother had it coming eventually we
learned that the bride left the employ
of the enigmatic bill to pursue a normal
life but at the rehearsal for her
wedding bill found her and he and his
top assassins killed all of the guests
and left the bride for dead miraculously
though she survived and began her path
of vengeance the first film is heavier
on action particularly in the climax in
the Japanese restaurant the house of
blue leaves it's there that the bride
has a darkly hilarious and visually
stunning showdown against the sword
wielding crazy 88 Kill Bill Vol 2
arrived in two theaters just one year
later it dives deeper into the bride's
background and the reasons for her war
with bill the entire to film saga is a
wonderful cinematic achievement that all
action movie fanatics should experience
at least once American audiences may not
be familiar with the name zato Ichi
but in Japan the fictional blind
swordsman is eminently recognizable
between 1962 and 1989 Japanese actor
Shintaro katsu
starred as zato Ichi in 26 films along
with 100 episodes of the zato Ichi TV
series that aired from 1974 to 1979 in
2003 Takeshi Kitano revitalized the hero
with the blind swordsman zato Ichi which
he directed wrote and starred in as the
legendary samurai character in the film
zato Ichi is an otherwise peaceful
swordsman who helps a pair of sisters in
their quest to make criminals pay for
killing their parents the movie is a
series of contradictions that shouldn't
work together but somehow they do it's
as bloody as a typical samurai film
while it also manages to be hilarious
and often beautiful gitanos unique style
makes these warring notes work perfectly
with big laughs and bigger stylized
bloodletting as time out critic Jeff
Andrews put it the blind swordsman zato
Ichi is without doubt fast funny
fabulous to behold in many ways 1965
samurai assassin is a tragedy of
Shakespearean proportions its hero is
pseudo geol needle Aronian who knows
he's the illegitimate son of a powerful
nobleman desperate to be recognized as a
true samurai he joins a plot to
assassinate a controversial Lord he
hopes that this will earn his father's
pride and encourage him to reveal
himself based on an actual incident in
Japanese history samurai assassin can at
times get bogged down with the
exposition that provides historical
context but its payoff is a stunning
brutal battle in the snow at the end of
the film which makes the wait more than
worth it fans of happy endings may want
to skip samurai assassin as it includes
a surprise twist that makes everything
that unfolds seem even starker and more
senseless regardless it's a captivating
presentation of tragic historical events
that eventually lead to the end of the
samurai check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]